people are becoming addicted to all the
technology the Twitter and the Facebook
and I know the kids are on the snapchat
and all that stuff a software firm front
rage surveyed more than 800 smartphone
users from all over the world to see how
they felt about technology usage and
addiction 53% of people feel anxious
when they can't use their phone I think
we've all felt that a little bit
there was a 39% increase in frustration
levels when they couldn't check their
emails or social networks and we're 79
percent more anxious when they couldn't
call or text people 45% use their phones
at least once an hour and 66% admitted
they couldn't go a day without their
gadgets because they're actually pretty
high but I definitely can see the
argument for that seems low I mean you
you use your phone once an hour I think
I'm looking at it every few even though
I would say yes I'm a little bit
addicted but if I left my phone at home
oh whoops I've left my phone at home and
you just have to deal with it sure
you're thinking how am I missing a call
and my gosh I should check my emails but
you know one of my girlfriend's brandy
she is constantly on her phone and I'm
like I think you need to put that down
because it's like all the time and it's
a little annoying you know you've been
at dinners where people go put them in
the bowl and everybody has to take out
their cell phones and the first person
who reaches for their phone has to pay
for dinner yeah so I actually I was at a
party this weekend and I did that and a
couple other people we all stacked up
our phones and we were present and aware
and we had what do we do about this
because we're all suffering from it I
mean I see this all the time you know
back in the day if you were watching a
sports game even something so simple
you'd watch a game and you can watch
with some friends or by yourself and
that's it but now it's like everyone's
even tweeting sports games like ever oh
he scored great I saw a tweet like
there's something going on here I really
some thinking this stuff is really
starting to affect our brains and our
back in all that it is actually
affecting our brain so there's a lot of
cognitive science where they followed
you know how they do tests with rats
experiments with rats where they give
them a treat and then they show that the
little electrodes in their brain show
that the we reward Center lights up and
there was another study that I had read
a while ago about people who check with
Facebook and they get the same lighting
up part of their brain the reward center
lights up every time they check Facebook
so these they think that it has to do
something that has to do with our need
to have that instant gratification and
the more we get accustomed to having
instant gratification it becomes like a
drug it has the same influence as
something like cocaine does yeah instant
instant I remember I you know we're all
doing it so it's not shamed it's not
like something that you probably like
it's something in this culture that all
of a sudden we're now the internet-based
instant at your fingertips information
people it's just the way it is I mean
what there's that new baby seat that has
the attachment for the iPad for babies
so even though babies should not be
looking at a screen for two years of
their life and I have a three-month-old
and sometimes I'll pick up my phone if
somebody's calling or something and I
see him looking at the bright light and
I'm like no no I tried to turn it away
from him but I mean children I see
little kids I can't even talk yet and
they know how to unlock their mom's
phone but what are you gonna do that's
technology today and that is gonna be
their life in their world they've never
no I I remember going to school and
learning how to do long form how to log
into a computer in like middle school
now kids have known swipe technology
since they were born and that's just
gonna be their life yeah and have you
seen these videos where these kids
because they're on the iPads all the
time they'll even see like a fish tank
something actually real and they can't
and they're trying to swipe that or a TV
no people think it's so cute but it's
actually dangerous that's scary and it
takes awareness I think you know you ask
what do we do about this I think a lot
of that has to do parenting actual
parenting and awareness you know and
that's a very difficult thing you know
we to get that awareness out to parents
you know it's taken this long for us to
have PSAs that tell parents how to feed
their children fruits and vegetables and
it's hey you're the boss of a TV
eventually I think you know as a society
we tend to just roll one headfirst into
the new technologies without figuring
out what the social aspects of it are so
we tend to find out you might take a
long time might take a generation to
figure out really unfortunate because
we're gonna have a lot of a TV short
attention span kids coming up and then
you prescribe adderall to all of them I
mean then it becomes this
self-fulfilling prophecy we ran over
medicated society so you create a
situation where people want instant
gratification all the time then they
can't pay attention to anything so you
give them a drug for that and then with
an issue with an instant response rather
than actually like finding ways to
adjust their behaviors yeah it's
actually I think now that you know in
the mornings I used to log on to a
website well I'd stopped watching
television news a long time ago because
they're so behind and you'd want you
know you look up all your sites online
and now I just go to twitter because I
follow all the new things and you fault
you see breaking news as it happens
it is infective yeah because the first
thing I wake up in the morning I grab my
phone and I'm like oh my god that's
happened oh that person just died oh
that's tragic I mean but that's how
you're finding it like right then and
now I mean celebrities don't even need
publicists anymore because they just go
make their own you know a statement on
Twitter or Facebook right so there's so
there's obviously good in it that kind
of thing and you can get news quickly
and they can share it but that is the
addictive quality of it so have you guys
ever had the phantom buzz of course so
like where you hear a phone and you're
like that me my husband's like no that's
my phone oh my god I really believe it's
doing things that it's where you
suddenly think your phone is vibrating
and then you realize it's not even in
your pocket I mean these are things that
are actually happening and we taught we
joke about it but it's actually I think
the interesting thing if I remember from
that study that they just did that when
people went without their devices for a
little while they did find that you know
after I think that reaching a peak of
anxiety they actually relaxed and they
put it down they were very proud of
themselves are not picking it up again I
think that that shows that it can work
just simple behavior adjustment yeah my
girlfriend and I joke that sometimes you
know you grab everything when you're
leaving the house you grab your purse
you grab your keys you're like okay do I
have everything and you walk out and
you're like wait a minute where's my
phone and we joke that it's our oxygen
because you take two steps then you go
where's my phone it can't breathe
without it and you have to run back in
and grab your phone before you even get
in the car I mean I realize it as I'm
walking out the door I don't even get to
five minutes later and go do I have my
phone no it's like an instant where is
it it's one of these things where it's
like everyone always wants to harken
back to another time you know it's sort
of like Midnight in Paris you always
think something that you didn't live
through was better than what you're
living through but there think about how
fundamentally different if you were to
take the life of someone growing up in
the in the 1950s versus what's happening
now I mean this this genuinely is going
to change everything about humanity and
how we we operate with each other right
it's already changing it's already done
okay I remember going to concerts you
know you would go it's like going to the
Staples Center and you're like you you
wouldn't be like hey where are you oh
yeah I see you're walking towards me
okay cool hey great and then you hang up
the phone and you're already face to
face I remember it's like okay as soon
as the concerts done I'll meet you by
the bathroom a Paul D in the mezzanine
level and just stay there don't don't
move you know and you would just sit
there and you would wait for somebody
because you beforehand you would talk
about where you were gonna meet you
didn't have cell phones you couldn't
text you didn't know where anybody was
how do you have we ever meet anyone for
dinner I have no idea just for the
record though I do want to say that I've
been basically taking Sundays off
Twitter basically see you know five or
ten or twenty tweets but that's it are
you having any phantom I'm having it
right now constantly